you've been working really well and i've
been looking with delight at how much
working you're putting down so it's not
like just an answer appears out of
nowhere i can see why you've done it so
big thumbs up on that i've given these
last four examples because each one kind
of highlights um they all have kind of a
weird curveball in them slightly
different ones and so i just want to
sort of go through each one if you're in
the middle of a question right now maybe
leave a bit of space to finish that um
but i will run out of space eventually
so you may like to jot some of this down
as i go but i just wanted to point you
out that uh yeah these are questions
which look very similar to the other
ones
but there are things i want us to note
so let's have a look at question five
together
it's log of and then you've got this
quadratic inside
the brackets up here okay now the first
thing i want to point out is and i've
left these two previous examples on the
board
this
question five is going to use the chain
rule in much the same way that we did it
here
and even similar to that one over there
have which handle you might have noticed
and it's why i put it in a different
color it can be quite tiresome to write
the whole u equals this d y into u d u
on dx it's just long right now it is
helpful it makes it so you don't confuse
things in your head you guys know what
it's like when you try and keep all the
stuff up here and then it just gets
jumbled onto the page however once
you're comfortable
you should actually be able to say
especially using a formula like this
like it's quicker it's more efficient
don't feel like you need to go the long
way around every time so here i'm going
to go immediately to an f dash
on f situation this
is the f of x or the u of x or you can
call it anything you like
can you just read off the derivative of
that formula
2x plus 5. now that there's the
numerator
and the denominator is going to be
whatever was there to begin with so in
this case it's x squared plus 5x
plus 6. so it's really nice like you're
finished you don't have to do any more
just like differentiating exponentials
is quite easy
logs same deal okay
now i'm going to leave a little bit of
space under there you'll see why in a
second
before we have a look at six we'll
return to five
this one here
might give you a little bit of pause
what did i say plus one minus four
okay now the reason why you might pause
is because you're like ah gross it's a
quotient so when you do your f dash on f
it's not quite so simple as just saying
f dash is a nice easy thing like that f
dash of this
is a mess okay and this is what i need
you to remember and you've seen this
before in the last couple of weeks
before you go to start differentiating
sometimes there's a way that you can
rewrite to make it nicer to work with
right
think back to our starter questions from
today is there a way before you
differentiate that you can rewrite this
to make it much easier to work with
abbas what do you reckon
so when you say i agree i think we need
to do something with x minus four it's
the fact that it's a fraction that's
gross what do you mean by bring it to
the top like so you move it to the top
and then in brackets you change the
index to minus one
oh okay so you're suggesting
is this what you're suggesting
we write this as log of x plus one and
then x minus four to the negative one so
you're suggesting okay now i've seen
this trick pulled a couple of times
within the room i'm gonna suggest it is
correct but there's not a huge advantage
you get out of it because when you do
product all this guess what it's still a
pain in the butt okay
slightly less maybe but product rule and
question rule are really the same thing
just dressed up differently especially
when your index is negative so it'll
just be gross okay
there's another way this is a legitimate
way of rewriting this but there's still
another way of rewriting it that will
make this like i promise it'll just fall
out you'll see the derivative like
you'll write it as easily as you wrote
this one
any suggestions
yeah go ahead
yeah so this one log
with division you can break into two
different logs now usually we would say
that's worse right but watch this with
me can you see now how much easier this
is
to work with
hello who are you looking for
i'll let them i'll let them know at the
end of this thank you
okay
so this is really important by the way
i've seen a number of you do something
similar to this you're like simplifying
and then you say oh i'm now up to the
stuff where i the step where i
differentiate and so you just say
equals if i'm about to differentiate
is the derivative just equal to that
it's not is it so let's make sure we
write this properly this is d y on dx
okay now this thing you barely even need
to think
this is going to be f dash on f which in
this case is
one there's the f dash over
x plus one there's the f and then you
just
do it again so here's the new
f so f dash is
also one
and then here's the new
f over here
i'm finished i mean you could put them
together you get a common denominator
but but but i'm okay with this okay and
the reason why i left a gap up here is
because you can pull the same kind of
trick up here can't you did you notice
that
look at this thing it doesn't look like
a product at the moment but you can
fairly easily write it as one
how would i write this as a product it'd
be log of 2x
hold on just be careful this is the
thing i'm factorizing yeah this thing x
squared plus five x plus six it's a nice
easy quadratic i think you can deal with
x plus 2
perfect okay so if that's another way of
rewriting this i could also write it as
two
separate logs do you see that
and so therefore when you differentiate
it'd be 1 over x plus 2
1 over x plus 3. if you took those two
fractions and put them together sure
enough
you'll get this same result but it's
like less mental work okay
all right so just be mindful and don't
forget as well you know there's a plus
here there's a minus there
now for question three and four there's
some really sneaky stuff in here so i'm
going to ask you i put you put your
laptop list down before but i want you
to bring them back up and just get
desmos ready for me i'm not going to
tell you what to put in it yet
but we will come back to it in a second
i just want it to be primed
okay
why did i change color
now like i said each of these has a
teeny tiny curveball in it and desmos is
going to help us work out the curveball
for both of them so question seven
y equals log
of 3x
okay if we just use the rule we've been
using something weird comes out
what will
f dash
on f don't simplify it what will f dash
on f be equal to in this case
3
on
3x which of course some of you are
already mentally simplifying you're like
oh
that's just 1 over x now hopefully
that's like some of you say oh that's
cool great it's simple i'm done move on
to the next question and others of you
look at and say
wait what what
like
this is not log x
which i know has this derivative
but that looks pretty right like there's
not much to screw up here like it's
correct how can this have the same
derivative
as this aren't they like pretty
different functions
we're going to see that actually they're
not as different as you think on desmos
can you can i ask you to put both of
these in for me
graph log x and if you type in ln it
should do the job for you
and then put in ln of 3x
and you should see it right
let me just pull it open here
yeah okay so hopefully it gave you a bit
of a head start on me but
there you go
now sure enough when you look at these
it's a bit hard to see but these are the
same
graph except one's just moved up now to
prove it and you can actually do this a
bit easier than i can but i'm going to
grab this ruler out if you get a ruler
out or even a pen
and put it against your computer screen
watch this right
anywhere you go
right anywhere you go along here
can you see it's the same distance
vertically it does look like the graphs
get closer together but if you just look
up and down take your ruler put it
against the screen over here
it's the same distance all the way along
in other words these are the same graph
just
shifted vertically and that's a really
important phrase
it's shifted vertically which means the
gradient hasn't changed and i can prove
it
pick your pen back up again
underneath where you're putting this
working y equals log of 3x
i'm going to pull my question 5 trick on
it see this right it's a product so i
can break it into two logs right how
would i break that
into two logs it'll be y equals
ln 3 plus
ln x now log3 you've got to calculate it
i mean desmos is open i'm guessing it's
something like 1.0 something or other
1.09 there you go
so this is just
uh 1.1 i think is a better rounding it's
just a number 1.1 it's a weird number
but it's just a number
so you can see these two graphs share a
lot more than you think right just one
of them
one of them is the other one moved up a
little bit and when you move it the
gradient doesn't change position and
gradient are different like that
make sense all right here comes the last
one
question four we are differentiating
and again you'll need um desmos ready
there for a second log of x
squared and the squared is inside okay
help me out again can we do f dash on f
what do you get daniel
x 2x over x squared looks good and then
of course you can simplify further right
you can say oh 2 over x
now can i ask you to go right back to
the start of your working today you
remember i told you that the derivative
of log x
it's kind of one over x but i said there
was a thing over here there was a
restriction it isn't all of one over x
which part is it
it's the x is greater than zero part
like so
now all the way through this has kind of
been implied that it's like not all of
that it's just a part
but now i want you to look back at this
guy can you go to desmos and put this
into the graph
log of and make sure the squared is
inside
you might need to use brackets to make
sure
do you see what's going on what's
happened
can you explain to me what we're looking
at
michael what do you think oh it's better
so there is a reflection isn't there
there's a horizontal reflection across
the y-axis now my question to you is
why like uh or maybe i should say x
where did it come from right why why is
there this other version of the log
curve on the other side anyone tell me
what what are your recommendations yeah
yeah so when you square right you get
this symmetry between left and right
okay now if you go to your calculator
can you get it out first or put it into
desmos if you like if you put in
something like ln of and put a negative
number in there any negative number you
like like negative one for instance what
does your calculator tell you
it's not very happy with you is it what
does it tell you it says error okay now
i need you to understand why it's the
thinking that matters here not the
answer okay
ln is short for log base e
and then i've got this number in here
remember right back to the start right
this means e to the power of something
e to the power of something gives you
negative 1.
e to the power of nothing gives you
negative one at least not the numbers we
know about right
if e to the power of i can't think of
any number gives you negative one then
that's why your calculator hands back to
you sorry dude i've got nothing for you
okay
however
when you
square
this negative one gets squared what does
it become
one and suddenly we're back in a normal
land that your calculator is quite happy
with right i know what to do with that
it's going to be
well in this case that would be 0
because e to the power of 0 is 1. okay
so that's why you get this other side of
the graph which is a little bit weird
but actually very important so this
it exists everywhere and it's like a
really classic curveball that the hsc
loves to throw up people say are you
really paying attention because this is
actually different to all the rest okay